okay today I'm going to talk to you
about half-life now the hard life of a
radioactive isotope is the time taken
for half of the room of the undecayed
nuclei to decay so first of all what we
need to know is what is the Kami so
decay just means to break down
radioactive nuclei shown here by the red
nuclei right here these show that these
are unstable they could break down at
any time this breaking down is called
decaying now what the half-life is is
the time taken for half of these nuclei
to decay so what I'm doing is I'm just
randomly picking four of those nuclei to
have decayed between this time and this
time so these four have now decayed as
they decay they emit means give out
radiation so the same amount of time
will be in between as here as it will be
here so we can see that there's four
remaining unstable radioactive nuclei so
between these two places another two are
going to decay and more radiation is
emitted by the ones that just decayed so
we can see this time in between half of
the nuclei decaying is called the
half-life and as we can see each time
each time we have decay less radiation
is emitted at each point so we're going
to look at how to do a half-life
calculation so a typical question might
be we start off with a thousand V Q this
just means backwards this is just a
measure of radioactivity and after six
hours a six hour period we take another
measurement and we now have 125 VQ for
crows so the question will be what is
the half-life how long does it take for
half of these radioactive nuclei to
decay so what we need to do is we start
off with a thousand
this is the amount of radioactive
radioactivity we detected at the
beginning so in order for half of these
radioactive leak created a K on next
reading would be 500 this shows that
half of those radioactive nuclei have
decayed however this isn't at our
desired number quite yet so all we do is
we imagine this half of these nuclei
decaying so this time we have a reagent
of 250 again although we've done is
we've divided by 2 to get half the
number of radioactive nuclei again we're
not a desired value so we're going to do
it again again half of these radioactive
nuclei decay as given this now our
correct reading so we can see it's taken
six hours to get from 1,000 to 125 and
we've gone through three different
half-lives so in order in order to
calculate the half-life what we do is we
take six hours which is the whole time
it's taken to get from here to here and
we divide it by three because we have
gone through three separate half-lives
so the half-life of this particular
radioactive material is two hours we can
also we can also find the half-life from
a graph so up the y-axis we might have a
reading of radioactivity in so
radioactivity again in BQ along the
x-axis we might have time in hours now
radioactivity graphs look like this
please notice that it never reaches zero
because each time two nuclei adjust half
so it never ever reaches zero
so to find using a graph to find the
half-life what we need to do is this so
let's say that 500 at time 0 we have
this much radiation 500 BQ so what we do
is we think well 1/2 part of 500 is 250
so what we have to do is we have to
extrapolate the graph and we see how
long it's taken for half of those
radioactive nuclei to decay so the
answer is 1 hour for this particular
substance now different isotopes can
have very different half-lives it could
be a matter of seconds or it could be
millions of years it depends on how
unstable the radioactive nuclei are so
just to recap half-life is the time
taken for 1/2 of the radioactive nuclei
to decay the amount of radiation emitted
decreases over time because there's
fewer nuclei to left to decay and here
is how to calculate
half-life using a calculation and here's
how to calculate a half-life using a
graph thank you